all right hello this is a another
instructional video from pepper panic
tips calm this is for new players of the
game and it's about how peppers work if
you if you're familiar with other king
games candy crush saga or farm hero saga
in particular those are match three
games and you know that it works by
matching three three or more pieces of
the same color together in order to you
know achieve goals that each level sets
out for you
pepper panic saga is a match three game
also but the peppers work a little bit
different than say the candies and candy
crush saga do so I'm gonna I'm gonna
load up this level it has a lot of it is
a big board and a lot of peppers on it
so I'm going to show you some of the
basics of how the peppers work level 95
is a match patterns level I'm not gonna
worry about the patterns on this or
trying to beat the level I'm just gonna
show you some basic moves alright so you
can see when we start out we have a
bunch of peppers all the peppers have
one dot on them and then they're all
small these are stage one peppers the
the objective in pepper panic saga is to
grow your peppers and the more you grow
them they'll eventually get to to their
full size and they'll explode and that's
what makes the game fun is there's a lot
of action compared to some of those
other games I mentioned so the way you
grow a pepper is you match three of the
same color together so I'm gonna move
this red one up here and now you'll see
that the new pepper that's left behind
has two dots same with the blue all
right so you see that whenever whenever
we match them together all three of them
don't disappear like they do in candy
crush saga they I guess if you played
farm heroes and you know about eggs how
eggs
all pulled together at the spot of the
one that you move so you see that when I
combine those three I have one pepper
left behind that's now a bigger size all
right so when I match this stage to
pepper with these other stage ones
you'll see it grows again all right now
it's got three dots one of the things
you can do in this game is you can
combine more than three at a time and
different things will happen I'm gonna
make this match here that's a it's a
four pepper match that's in a straight
line
and you'll see that you'll see that
something a little bit different happens
all right so whenever I combine those
four Peppers what happened was I create
what was called a shock wave the shock
wave that comes particularly from a four
four pepper match in a straight line
will clear all the small level all the
small peppers out of that row and grow
your one pepper so now you see at the
bottom I have this big pepper that's
about ready to explode and it had
cleared out all the small peppers in my
row another way you combine peppers that
can be helpful is by combining them in
patterns like this one this is going to
be a tea pattern as you can see it's
gonna be five peppers that are all
combined together the same color and the
pattern is going to be a tea so what
else is gonna happen is this this pepper
is at stage 5 that you can see it as
five dots on it it's gonna explode when
it explodes watch what happens to the
other blue peppers on the board
it happens kind of fast so I'll explain
the each time you explode a pepper of
one color you grow it to its full size
and it explodes it will grow all the
other peppers of that color on the board
so you see all the one you know stage
one peppers that were there and now now
stage twos and you also well we'll talk
about that in a second
so I'm gonna continue to you know
combine these blue peppers if I can you
can use I want to grow these right here
and they're already partially grown so
when I collect when I connect these four
it's gonna create another one of their
shock waves like it did in the first
time but this time watch it'll grow
these two peppers because they're not
small and that started you know the
effect of where that that pepper
combined with some other ones that
exploded alright so this is another one
this is a you know a couple to stage two
peppers combined with the stage 4 pepper
that's gonna make that grow big enough
to explode grew all the other red
peppers on the board see those were
three two state stage two peppers
combined it only made it a stage Stage
five so it's ready to explode but it
didn't explode just by that match
here's another four pepper combo you see
the shock wave this one's gonna be four
and this one's gonna serve two purposes
it's gonna explode this pepper that's
ready to explode it's also gonna shoot a
shock wave but this one that's gonna
make it explode so watch what happens
here see both of those peppers are
burning and they explode and now all the
other ones of that color that starts a
chain reaction which causes peppers all
over the board to start to explode and
it's gonna start what's called a pepper
panic pepper panics are cool in the fact
that they you know they get you lots of
points and they clear out the board as
you can see after that happened all the
other peppers disappeared and new ones
fell in that were stage ones that can
come in handy too also like if you're
trying to make something and you can't
get to it you can clear out the board
here's an interesting match this one's
gonna be two teas together so the
matches like that are obviously going to
cause a lot of action to happen on the
board and make things you know good
things happen these I see that these are
ready to explode this one's ready to
explode if I make a four pepper match
here it's gonna make that one explode
one of the things about making pepper
panics is is then you have a pepper like
this it's always going to explode if the
grows one size if I can align these
three together that one pepper is gonna
grow and explode but if I combine these
three together
watch what happens this one will explode
and that will cause a chain reaction
that causes that one to explode so
taking your time before you make your
moves is helpful too to get the most as
far as chain reactions and starting
pepper panics
all right as well as making them in the
shape of T's you can also make them in
the shape of ELLs this is two peppers of
the same color here two peppers of the
same color here and the fifth one
that'll fit in between so whenever I
combine those the same thing happens
that happens with the T it sends off to
shockwaves and creates a lot of good
stuff to happen on the board
there's one more kind of match that you
can do and I'm trying to set one up here
somewhere all right let's see
that looks like another pepper panic is
gonna start so hopefully we'll have some
peppers fall into place
like I said earlier you know this is a
board that I picked on purpose because
it has a lot of it has a lot of
wide-open space and a lot of peppers
some of the levels are obviously gonna
be a lot more difficult to you know make
the matches that you want I'm out of
move so I'm gonna pause the video for a
second and then I'm gonna load it up one
more time alright so I I reloaded the
level and I move some peppers around
like a buddy I'll show you the last type
of match that you have this is a match
that matches five peppers together in a
straight line and it acts a little bit
differently than the other five pepper
matches that are in shapes when you
match the peppers this way what it'll do
is it'll it'll grow all the peppers on
the board in this case of the same color
in this case yellow peppers and it also
on levels that feature the the villain
mr. Claus it'll actually disable him too
so these are good these are good matches
it does not make it does not make a
shockwave so you know you have to use
your best judgement of what the better
match would be in different situations
but this is just a basic straight line
five pepper match then you see that all
of the yellow peppers on the board grew
alright so I hope this was helpful to
understand how peppers work in the game
and how you can use them a little bit
differently than you do you know candies
or whatever I mean in a way they're all
they all turn into boosters if you grow
them because they explode and that
causes a lot of different things to
happen I think it's a fun game I play it
and I and I make my website about the
game so I hope you'll visit and you know
check out all my videos and all the
guides on how to beat particular levels
and tips that you need and I'll be
making some more videos so I'll see you
soon